good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy hump day it is a wetness
day hope everyone is getting down
getting dirty humping someone they love
speaking of people I love hey Jax good
morning good morning mcclurgia happy
hump day to you and yours I hope thank
you celebrating safely
I am I'm celebrating hump day by
recurting with mcclurgia
you're recruiting with mcclurdia yeah
I'm recording with mclartia I think
we're all recurting with mclartia
because I'm not mclartia like mcclurgia
is like a separate being yeah you told
me the funnest fact the other day yes
when you did your show in Nashville and
everybody came to the meet and greet
every person walked up to you and called
you mcclurgia Jackie uh like
first of all I've never seen something
that we do catch on so quickly yeah
especially because it's not been really
rolled out in any sort of major way we
didn't make it like a big deal like kind
of just been calling me McClure yeah and
I I kind of like admitted a few months
ago that that's what like I've been
whenever I think of Emily radakowski's
ex-husband like I always think to myself
like Sebastian McClure yet don't ask me
why and I admitted that on breaking
bread where Secrets went to be shared
Secrets Revealed it really resonated
with people because now that's your name
Jackie they walked into the meet and
greet they were like mcclurgia I was
like what that is so funny and I'm so
Overjoyed to hear this so am I I'm also
Overjoyed because today finally a secret
project in the making for nine months
has has finally been shared with the
world Jackie and I have known for a long
time and for some of us me it's been
extremely difficult to keep this secret
to myself but I did if you follow our
sister Olivia on Instagram you know that
she gave birth to her second baby boy
that's why I'm coming
um down this week I kept talking about
my trip and I was like I wonder if
people are going to be like questioning
my trip nobody will ever question when
you're coming to see your Best gal now
they will and to podcasts in front of
the flamingos like you're doing it for
the flamingos but I'm also doing it for
my new nephew our new nephew I'm an and
to once again I'm back on the NT train
uh your auntie once over
chicka chicka chicka chicka chicka
chicka chicka
chicka chicka chicka chicka chicka
chicka chicka the anti-express is on its
way to Florida tomorrow don't count out
yet empty that's the thing I feel like
people are constantly counting out that
aunties and they shouldn't be yeah I
feel like for you your auntie
isms have been
record high you know rolled was born
this year you became an auntie again but
like I haven't been in Auntie since
K Laura was born you know and like then
before that it was Bruno joined the
family so like I really haven't had like
fresh anti who's older Kaylor Magnolia
their birthdays are one day apart
I have literally no idea and one thing
about me I feel like this is a good time
to share since you brought it up one
thing about me is like
I literally do not know my nieces and
nephew's birthdays like I know the month
and like the general but like let me
think Michaela's birthday is in May
and I want to say it's the 21st
I think that's nice it's not birthday
Michaela's the 22nd
okay and roldini's birthday
I know it's in February
and I'm gonna go with the 12th 13th
you're just see every time you have your
guess just add one okay I like was
singing that this morning or yesterday
because someone was like how old is
Michaela I was like telling a friend of
mine that Olivia had given birth and I'm
like that's an amazing question let's do
the math and I could not remember her
birthday that's so funny do you know
Bruno's birthday or chance you don't
even know Bruno's birthday of course I
know my boy my first boy well then you
let the day go by without acknowledging
it because the most recent of Bruno's
birthdays I was at your house and you
come into my room at midnight and you
were like by the way it was Bruno's
birthday today yeah we were going
through a lot of change here Bruno
understood Bruno did understand so when
were you at my house
August yeah
17th 15th pretty good wow that was like
a total blind guess in the dark honestly
gorgeous
so much simcha and Mazel here in our
family thank you everyone who's reached
out with the kind words not to make
everything about us but
um Olivia like
it's kind of like giving Kylie energy
like it's giving Chloe you know it is
it's been so it's been so like on the DL
obviously but she's just been like
living her life and just hadn't normally
publicly I actually was with her
yesterday and she did say like she is so
willing and excited to share her story
on the patreon like to talk about won
her birth story and to like why she
never shared it publicly that she was
pregnant all this time so that will be
upcoming whenever she is ready for it
but like she's like ready to go she's
ready and chat
speaking of patreon the fact that we're
going to be together starting tomorrow
means the patreon is going to be
absolutely lit Florida Vlogs Florida
pods Florida Tings Florida Chile
maybe we'll do another great chili
cook-off when Ben's here right Ben gets
there like a few days after me I think I
could handily defeat him
I don't think so handling I don't think
you could as the ship Heroes they were
chowing down on my chili no I'm sure why
I've been cooking so much is because
like Olivia's always the one cooking but
you know in these last few weeks like I
thought I would you know do something to
help out help out yeah um I think that
you could I think that now if you
watched a great chili cook-off you do
know that Jackie like very bizarrely
made vegetarian chili I wasn't
comfortable cooking with meat just yet
meat is so scary like you didn't even
stand a chance tagged me in the funniest
meme today it like I I saw it as I was
waking up so it didn't register but it's
just coming back to me and I'll I
remember it now it's like she's a 10 but
she overcooks her chicken because she's
scared it's gonna be raw no totally and
the caption was like it might be dry but
at least it's safe so true literally me
but with the OG chili cook off like you
truly didn't even stand a chance because
like you're vegetarian so I don't know
if you could be Ben but you can compete
like you now definitely like are gonna
give him a run for his money but he
makes chili so frequently and he's been
doing it for so long and like I don't
know it's gonna be really tough to beat
him you know I just feel like I have
this passion for chili as seen in my
mentions because I only get tagged in
Chili's now I know chili they tag me
like if I just want to go on chili and
spoke just look through my mentions
um and I just feel like that comes
through when I'm cooking whereas for Ben
100 it's like Dave another day another
chili what are we making today the
passion is there and I just feel like
you can taste the heart and soul and
mind because I put my foot in it
I put my foot in it
um so make sure you're headed over to
patreon.com to not miss out on all the
family fun happening this month and we
are doing two q and A's before all of
that starts we always do a few General q
and A's every few months till they catch
up with your girlies and we always
answer them together but we had a little
bit of a different idea because I feel
like these days the questions for you
and I are different we're different
girls a little just a little so we're
gonna do like Claudia interviewing me
with your guys's questions and me
interviewing Claudia with your guys's
question so it's more tailored it's very
Diane Sawyer very
and speaking of Diane Sawyer we've got a
Fab episode today it's Wednesday which
means we have deer toasters and we've
got three girls who have found
themselves in unique situations oh
really so I'm looking forward to being
able to change lives at the end of
today's episode and I hope you'll join
us
I do hope you will
there's also no TV recap because there
was nothing on TV last night I've been
watching the empress another two
episodes just so delectable I finished
that book you recommended okay you can
bash me in a second let me just I'm not
gonna bash you can share your thoughts
in a second let me just talk about the
empress because it's really like renewed
my
interest in European royalty I feel like
it was laying dormant for a while but
now I've been like reactivated and I'm
just like in my sleep you know when you
watch something you read something like
you sleep in dream about it as you toss
and turn you're just like of course the
Austrian Empire a hundred percent that's
where I am right now and I just love it
so like I love it so much and even when
I was like in my thoughts and my dreams
and like being like
confused it was a good place to be so I
feel like I'm gonna go back down the
rabbit hole once I finish this show and
I would recommend it to anyone who has a
any inkling for his star an itch for the
history
um I did finally finish the redheads
book of the month that you and Margo
thought I would like I gave it three
stars it was far too long
and truly
truly pointless like I like what was the
point what was the plot like I wasn't
sure like what if someone were to be
like what's this book about I would be
like I'm not entirely sure I think it's
about a strong female protagonist making
her way through
a man's world and friendly time for
women
okay just for me that's not like a
strong enough plot um the book was right
and so based on the plot that's why I
wouldn't have recommended it to you but
I was okay with you reading it because I
thought one the writing is really strong
like it's well written yeah two for me
like Madden 6 30 are everything like
not mad she was just like a little
version of her mom and I wrote a little
Annoying I always love a precocious
camper
um I just thought it was fine like I'm
surprised that you guys all loved it so
much like it was fine
I I thought it was really really good
but I unders I I don't know that I would
have vehemently recommended that you
read it but
I'm glad that you did isn't it fun to
just like
Branch out a little bit and then it
reminds you why you love the things that
you love
that's for sure also my next book um I'm
gonna start today which came out
yesterday is the um it ends with us
second book it's called it starts with
us Colleen Hoover released yesterday did
you see that profile on Colleen Hoover
in the New York Times
it was insane it was filled with such
juicy information about like how many
books she sells you know book numbers
are totally private like you know like
the Bible sells a lot but if like your
favorite influencer writes a book like
you don't know how many copies they
actually sell so they had like
full-blown figures it was so interesting
you know in the last year she sold 20
million books that's more than like the
top three books that sell every year is
like the Bible like John Grisham or
something like the top three books she
has sold more than all of them combined
um she had like the pre-order for it
ends with us like the first printing is
two and a half million copies
it's just crazy and like how she's
really like not only changing the
publishing industry but changing how
people think about like Romance Writers
because like I think for a long time
Romance Writers were considered like you
know like Danielle Steel like not
serious authors yeah and she's really
changing that narrative it was an
incredible I mean obviously I didn't
read it I saw like Tick Tock summing it
up but it was an incredible profile and
I'm so happy for like yes Colleen yes
Colleen I haven't even heard about it
but I will definitely check it out I
love some facts and figures but it's not
surprising at all like when you look at
the New York Times bestseller listen
sometimes I I look just to see like
what's trending if there are any books
that look good that I haven't heard of
um
she is all over it and I also feel like
because the list is editorialized and
they pick and choose I feel like they're
also cut like making it they're not
giving her any higher accolades than she
has if anything I feel like they might
be taking some of her books off because
the whole list would be Coho would be
her and that's like not what the list is
about it's so how people discover books
and new Authors and everything and I
actually feel like they're probably
editorializing it like not in her favor
yet I completely agree the way that the
New York Times bestsellers list like
really has nothing to do with how many
books you sold is something I only
recently learned as an author and I'm
like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] and like
you've seen books that have been on
there for two like Obama's book is still
on there like I have a hard time
believing I think when it when it was
released like millions and millions of
copies were sold but like years later
every week still selling 10 000 copies
like that's the kind of like the minimum
amount you need to get on the list like
I don't believe that I don't believe
that about green lights either by
Matthew McConaughey like I don't think
people are still in droves 10 000 books
a week so the fact that the New York
Times bestsellers list isn't based on
numbers and is solely based it's based
on numbers but also like their opinion I
don't really think that's there and
that's why like they don't get as much
Credence but if you make the USA Today
best sellers that's like that's a huge
accomplishment as well because those
numbers those charts are based on actual
sales exclusively nothing else yeah like
I think there's a number of books that
you can sell that like even if you're
you know an unsavory person New York
Times has to add you to the list
and then I think there are authors who
undersell but they are Darlings and you
know everyone's media Darlings everyone
loves history hype for their book even
though like no one wanted to really buy
it
um and those people will make the list
and so there's a lot of that but then
also they're so [ __ ] shady with their
daggers
uh this is a deeply personal
conversation because they say like if
your book has a dagger next to it then
you click the dagger and like at the
bottom it says like
they notice a trend of like bulk buying
and that like kind of it's like shady to
be like oh they bought their way into
being on the list it's basically saying
you bought your your own book but I just
like find it really coincidental all the
people who have daggers you know okay so
let me say I only found out what the
dagger was I think like most normal
human beings from younger
um that girl Quinn and like had a dagger
so I was like oh my God dagger and then
when I used to like follow like
celebrities and influencers books I
would be so interested to see like who
got a dagger and I was like I would be
like oh my God they have a dagger Shady
they bought their own book and then my
ass gets a dagger
um I literally have the phone call
recorded with my publisher where she was
like you made the New York Times I was
like yes yes she's like number 12 I'm
like yes yes she's like they did put a
dagger though I'm like what it like
undermined the entire accomplishment and
when I say I swear on my [ __ ] life I
didn't buy my own book like I don't have
to I have proof from Amazon I in my
pre-sale and my first week like let's
say it like I sold almost 30 000 bucks
like that to make the list you need to
sell around like eight to be safe ten
your ass my ass sold 30 between audio
video not video audio ebook and hard
copy like so I have nothing to be
ashamed of like I sold my own
[ __ ] books [ __ ] and I said to
my publisher I'm like first of all can
we reach out to the New York Times and
ask like for clarification like where
where are these bulk sales coming from
and of course they never responded and
my publisher was like well it might have
something to do with this meet and greet
that you did with The Strand so let me
tell you I did a meet and greet with The
Strand where you bought a book you got
it signed and you did like a virtual
because it was covid we sold 200 bucks
okay so at 200 and I was doing it to
support the Strand remember that whole
campaign support the Strand they were
almost going out of business during
covet so I'm over here helping local
Indie bookshops and the New York Times
is punishing May I don't think that's
why you have the dagger
that's what that was truly the only
reasonable explanation that my publisher
could come up everyone else who has a
dagger like it's just it's because I'm
like a controversial people they
begrudgingly have to put on the list
they could not deny the sales numbers
and if you look at the New York Times
list versus Amazon and something's
number one on Amazon it's not on New
York Times list it's like
yeah I that was like really upsetting
especially because then everyone's like
shame on her um back like family money
like [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up like first
of all I'm literally like a financially
independent Queen since I've been 18. so
eat my [ __ ] ass with a big dirty Fork
you [ __ ] and like I didn't like can I
just have one accomplishment that's mine
like I actually did it I sold tons of
books like because it was really good I
worked really hard on it like please
[ __ ] off
yeah and like it's it has occurred to me
just like this big dirty with because
you're a big dirty [ __ ] like it has
occurred to me because like every week I
would get from like the six months that
we started selling three months in
advance that we started selling the book
I would get like a sales report every
week like I have the proof like I didn't
buy my own [ __ ] book [ __ ] yeah she
has a storage unit full of books right
no oh and then like I like every author
I got a box of my own books like a
couple weeks before the book came out it
was the first time I'd ever seen it I
probably had a total of 25 books
she's not even ashamed she's posting
that she bought her own book first of
all uh it's my book [ __ ] I didn't have
to pay for it and two it came straight
from the warehouse not from like an
Amazon not from a retailer I get copies
of my own book like I need them right
and you need to give them to the redhead
so we could prepare for your episode I
need to do redheads I need to do
influencer gifting like and I just like
in my house I have like a shelf of like
10 or 15 copies of my own book because I
think that's where the dagger is a human
a hundred percent the dagger
conversation it's actually really crazy
how I used to really truly judge other
people who had them and now I'm
questioning every dagger no when you see
a dagger you question the New York Times
yeah don't question the author and I'm
sure that there are people like like I
feel like it happened yeah like Quinn I
feel like it happens in like you know
entrepreneur
um like crypto people I feel like they
do it I don't know why they're just like
hustle culture like rise grind and they
buy their own books like give them out
in the street like I feel like they're
definitely people who do it I'm swear on
my [ __ ] life that I literally it was
not me like I did not do that yeah now
we know and if I did I like wouldn't be
bringing it up like we would like skirt
around the conversation dagger wouldn't
have come out of my mouth
literally but like I truly have nothing
to hide except for my chin and my moles
but
besides that well I need to read that
Coho piece yes oh sorry that's what we
were talking about it was really
interesting speaking of books redheads
merch is dropping tomorrow I'm wearing
another thickening sweatshirt from The
Collection The Collection has been
posted at the redheads Instagram you can
see all the sweatshirts that are
dropping we have a long sleeve we have
hat we have tote we have accessories and
it's a really wonderful drop I I love
like I love this sweatshirt I love the
one I wore yesterday it's just like so
cool and
it's sickening sporty and literate
sporty and literate I gotta send one to
Ben
how are we staying at your house this
weekend yeah he would yes I was caught
exactly but he would never wear it
because he's so stubborn because he's so
stubborn but maybe he can't read what it
says
oh totally okay I got you this new uh
giant sweatshirt mix
the Knicks the Knicks
yeah but at MSG enjoy
that's so funny
um so tomorrow shopmorningtoast.com see
you there redheads
and I feel as though without a did it no
I feel as though without further did it
do I am ready are you ready yeah I'm
ready for the fast five stories that you
need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Clinique the even better clinical dark
spot interrupter if you have dark spots
it can often feel like a vicious vicious
cycle
as soon as one Fades another one pops up
but you can break the cycle with the
Clinique Even Better clinical dark spot
interrupter this powerful serum works
for melon and Rich to fair skin and it
helps visibly correct dark spots like
acne marks while protecting from future
discoloration so I suffer from dark
spots I get them from the Sun a lot of
people get them for different reasons
and it's really impossible to get rid of
them and if you do successfully get rid
of a dark spot another one pops up like
the next day
um and that's why the Clinique Even
Better clinical dark spot interrupter is
fabulous because Clinique is a brand
that you can trust their skin care is
fabulous and it has proven results so 94
of people demonstrated an improvement in
Radiance and visible skin tone including
acne marks in eight weeks and you can
see an overall 40 visible reduction in
dark spots in 12 weeks they also have
the damage eraser which is the CL 302
brightening complex it is more
concentrated it has boosted technology
to deliver dramatic brightening results
yet it is still gentle enough for all
skin types it is free of oil generated
alcohol SLS l-s-e-s sulfates parabens
flath lights fragrances it is oil-free
non-acnigenic fast absorbing and it is
dermatologist developed so you can get
even better clinical dark spot
interrupter this holiday season for you
or someone in your life who maybe is
working on their skin care it's
available at clinique.com and that
product again is that even better
clinical dark spot interrupter at
Clinique Dot home
today's episode is also sponsored by
better help it can be tough to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode when faced with a challenge in life
and that's why betterhelp is here and
they are sponsoring today's episode so
thank you so much to better help because
the therapist can help you become a
better Problem Solver they can make it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or small so whatever it
is that inspires you to start therapy
whether it's someone in your life who
really recommends it or something you've
just been wanting to do to get the tools
to help you tackle everyday life
um check out betterhelp because it is a
great option that is convenient
accessible affordable and the best part
is that it's done entirely online you
can get matched with a therapist after
filling out a brief survey and switch
therapists anytime for me that's one of
the greatest benefits of better help if
you've done therapy you know not always
are you going to be matched and the
first person is the perfect match for
you not every therapist is going to be
the best fit for you so they make it
really easy and like not awkward to
switch which is really great and a huge
benefit over in-person therapy so
whether you want to be a better Problem
Solver whatever it is that makes you
interested in therapy therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com toast
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash toast because when you
can learn how to find your own Solutions
in life there is no better feeling when
faced with a challenge so that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
toast to get 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t thank you mclartia
story Olivia Wilde shares her special
salad dressing recipe in response to her
former Nanny's allegations Olivia Wilde
is sharing the recipe for a special
salad dressing which turns out to be
taken from a classic novel about divorce
so we spoke yesterday about all these
allegations The Nanny made about Olivia
and Jason's marriage including one where
she made a salad for Harry went to bring
it to him and Jason laid under her car
so Olivia posted a screenshot of the
book that it's from which is heartburn
by uh
okay yeah yeah that's what I thought and
it has the ingredients for how to make
this salad dressing mix two tablespoons
gray pecan mustard with two tablespoons
good red wine vinegar then whisk
consistently with a fork slowly add six
tablespoons of olive oil until the
vinaigrette is thick and creamy this
makes a very strong vinaigrette that's
perfect for salad greens like arugula
and Watercress and endive
I I like that she's like playing into
this drama
um and like kind of like lightening the
situation a little bit but I believe it
was she who said you know the internet
is sufficiently nourished I don't need
to be feeding it and it looks like
you're doing just that she gave it
literally and metaphorically gave the
internet a salad
what is it what was it that she said I
feel like the internet is sufficiently
nourished I don't need to keep feeding
it something not to contribute yeah
yeah well she is contributing
she is contributing but honestly in a
pretty
great way I don't know like whoever
approved this PR if it was all her like
that's
that's how you address like something
and make light of it and we all can move
on it's like when Leah Michelle finally
started like addressing the fact that
she can't read yeah
it took her a little too long it did it
did and I mean on the one hand like
uh like the claims that the nanny made I
feel like they were the Jason and Olivia
had said like they're scurrilous and
untrue and this and that and then on the
other hand like here's the salad that
got you right
right so there was a salad so what else
is true it's a salad
did you see Liam Michelle got bangs I
didn't I thought she looked great she
did look really great but she always
looks great she does but it's very you
know life imitating art it's giving
Rachel Berry yeah but yeah her makeup
was like snatched like
she could have had a pixie cut honestly
she's really becoming like the darling
of the New York City like theater scene
she's out every night performing at
different events gala's charity events
TV shows and it must be nice you know
yeah are you jealous no no no no
people who need people
uh the luckiest people
in the
world they keep having her perform that
song like on TV on The Today Show she
did at this charity event and I wonder
why I wonder why too well I think she's
getting in all her press before that
documentary comes out
I also think they probably don't want to
spoil Don't Rain on My Parade and like
give it away for free also maybe there's
something about doing right on my parade
that doesn't maybe translate
or it's too involved like you need more
maybe this is just an easier song to run
onto the Today Show and thing right but
I also do think it's like giving the the
cow away for free the milk Did You Don't
Rain on My Parade right because that's
really what people go to say I don't
know but it's already out there her Glee
version
it's actually incredibly different in
what ways in the arrangement but also
just in the vibe you know what I mean
she's sauntering down the aisle saving
them no once again she's like this like
in the moment she's decided to give up
on her career and go find her man which
was a huge mistake and she's like so
excited and she's throwing her life away
and it's like in Glee she's like being a
star but in this she's just being Fanny
you know you know what it's giving hmm
the girl who didn't go to Paris
because she stayed with Jason Waller no
she's literally like
going back to Mr Ornstein even though
he's like a gambler and a crook also
that was a cultural shift when LC didn't
go to Paris you know we had this
conversation yesterday on the toast if
you missed it um about like moments in
pop culture and just general moments in
media that we look back on and realize
they truly shaped us as people and we
asked people on Instagram to
share what moments they experienced that
had that same effect we got over 3 000
comments and I'm just curious like where
all these commenters have been the past
couple of weeks but okay
um and these are the moments that people
really identified with Jessica Simpson
and Nick Lachey getting a divorce I was
a little young
the Brad Angelina Jen Saga yeah this is
a good one the Bad Romance music video
that is a good one the way we were all
doing those dance oh yeah and Lady Gaga
like when she was popping off like she
was Shifting the culture yeah oh Ashley
Simpson lip syncing on SNL yes that was
crazy
um oh I didn't watch a bachelor back
then but I imagine if you did Jason
breaking up with Mal with Melissa on
live TV for Molly was like huge I
remember that but I hadn't watched it
I've seen him but I just remember and I
just remember thinking like there's no
way that this isn't stage like that he
would no and they're still together
humiliate one girl and that the other
girl would like be so down for him even
though she was but now I don't think it
was stage no a lot of people said that
Jamie Lynn Spears getting pregnant in
the ending of Zoe 101 I was gonna say
that yesterday that did come to mind I
totally agree yeah I thought that was a
really good one oh this is a good one
too when Justin Bieber visited the Anne
Frank house and said that she'd have
been a believer
honest that really was he's not wrong no
honestly he's not wrong like that's the
whole point like she should have had
this Pure Life and she was hiding from
Nazis in the floor
um
oh and then most people did say
Britney's head shaving umbrella
breakdown of course though at the time I
I could I didn't understand what that
was about because I was five this was a
good one too when pumpkins spit on New
York in Flavor of Love it forever
changed me honestly same yep
and then somebody else when Lauren
didn't go to Paris is that good yes the
comments on there were like really
taking me back like down memory lane
someone had said when Nick Jonas
announced he had diabetes diabetes I
think for a lot of Nick Jonas fans like
that was a heart-wrenching moment I do
feel like
um when they announced that like they
didn't really specify that it was like
not the type of Diabetes you die from
but like the one that you live with yeah
that makes your life really hard
um so a lot of people thought he was
gonna die oh I don't remember thinking
that I feel like they specified the
stage I don't remember
or maybe just like the young kids the
young girlies weren't listening diabetes
and then they turned it off yeah wailing
anyways that was fun trip down memory
lane it was thank you all for sharing
and I think yesterday I spoiled the OC
for two people but sorry I know well
that was another conversation I wanted
to add I feel like we've spoken about
this a lot but like you know I was
thinking recently about starting Gilmore
Girls and I feel like if somebody said
you know Rory dies she doesn't but like
let's say like I can't be mad at them
I'm literally 20 years late you can't be
mad like when does the spoiler alert
statue of limitations expire I say five
years
so do I so like people being like not me
literally on season one of the OC while
listening to the toes like yeah Marissa
dies
and they play a beautiful song
I thought they played um
Imogen Heap
s yeah yeah I think when he walks away
it's that but then it's Hallelujah
for something else and then there's that
other song that they play do you know
what I'm talking about
there's so many songs
there are so many songs that I associate
with it was a very music oriented oh
this one like Champagne Supernova in the
sky yes
there's so many songs obviously
California
um and you know what else was a cultural
shift for me do you remember that show
Cheyenne yeah um
today literally that show was so good it
was Nothing's Gonna Stop Me anyway I'm
holding on
I'm strong so good everyone should do
the hanging on challenge
I'm hanging on
today
but nothing's gonna stop just like when
Gen Z and Millennial come collide
gen Z is vomiting
vomiting I feel like vomiting that's my
favorite line for myself that was a
cultural reset for us for nowhere for us
but us from Homemakers when the old man
realizes he's being conned and he's like
I feel like vomiting it's the and he's
like in his underwear too it's the best
line ties right spoiler alert 50 year
old movie the man dies
um but also that's just another thing I
think it like really varies from family
to family like what quotes from movies
stick with you like hey look at me which
is the most she's getting into my clams
because clams casino both are like the
two most obscure lines from Shallow Hal
that like no one would recall wait this
is the most obscure line that we're
obsessed with in our family from Borat
I'll do it I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
no it's like literally like from Borat
everyone's like oh it's very nice like
us no we're quoting that like one
college kid who was in the RV he was
like I'll do it I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
do it
it's so Random
oh wow and you know what was the
ultimate cultural reset
um like you know back in the day they
had the Industrial Revolution they did
we had sleepover the movie
I that actually was like a shift in
in the planet like I it was so big
so big and so important when you zoom
out and like through the lens of The Big
Bang Theory you could still see the
movie sleep over 100 you see the speaker
guy asking Nancy if she prefers celery
over brownies
and you see Steve being like Julie Julie
birthday
I think she was in our grade school bus
oh my God
yeah always comes back to sleepover that
is the true takeaway from today's
episode because we intentionally bring
it back right like yeah
okay ready for our next story
Matthew Perry is on the cover of people
opening up about his opioid overuse and
this weeks he secretly spent in a coma
so friends star Matthew Perry has given
his first tell-all interview in which he
details how his drug and alcohol
addictions secretly nearly cost him his
life the star 53 revealed he was given
just a two percent chance of survival
after an opioid addiction caused his
colon to burst when he was age 49
leaving him in a coma for two weeks and
spending months in a hospital a fact
which is Legions of fans were unaware of
after suffering from a gastrointestinal
perforation Matthew said he had to use a
colostomy bag for nine months has now
had 14 surgeries on his stomach in total
and been to rehab 15 times in a bid to
get clean
the actor sober actor detailed his
decades-long battle to rid himself of
the disease of addiction when he was
first admitted to the hospital he said
the doctors told my family that I had a
two percent chance to live I was put on
a thing called an ECMO machine which
does all of the breathing for your heart
and lungs and that's called a Hail Mary
no one survives that he said I wanted to
share when I was safe from going into
the dark side of everything again
by the way Matthew Perry should really
write a book one because he had like
this insane Fame and this insane [ __ ]
going on at the exact same time
like if you watch I feel like I've said
this before this is turning into like
one of my dentist stories
like the final episode of season five of
friends takes place on the same like
fictional day as season one of episode
six it's like the same night
um and Matthew Perry in like the three
months that they have off has like
gained and lost 40 pounds and you can
see how like his addiction is taking
such a toll on his body because like
Chandler when he proposes to Monica
they go out to celebrate he proposes of
the season finale and then the first
episode the next season they go out to
celebrate that night two different
people yeah and it's like only a few
months he said at one point during his
friend's career he admits he was taking
55 Vicodin a day and was down to 128
pounds but yet he didn't know how to
stop oh my God he said the friend's
castmates were understanding and they
were patient as he got older and
struggled with his disease
yeah I would really love a book for
Matthew Perry I feel like it would be
really good yeah have any of the Friends
cast members written books
I don't think like Memoirs no yeah
I mean it was a fascinating time in in
pop culture history and then also it was
a cultural reset not for me because
friends premiered in like what 1998 and
I was four years old like I only came to
friends when I was in college yeah I do
think for everyone who watched it live
it was and you know who has July me
what you used to watch it Friday nights
on the WB
what are you talking about no we didn't
yeah we did oh you were probably there
but like you weren't knowing you weren't
like handling the remote or like
irrelevant yeah irrelevant wait you
watched Friends I think so because I
remember no the WB memories it wasn't on
WB it was on NBC really yeah well we
were watching the WB maybe they played
reruns on the WB maybe yes we were
watching the wbw no we didn't only have
one channel we were only like allowed to
watch one channel and we didn't even
need another like we were happy with the
WB it's Buffy the Vampire I started
watching well obviously we watched like
kids programs like Barney and stuff but
then like when we were like 10 we
watched WB and then when we were like 14
15 we watched Disney Channel
like you're right it should be the
option we like age backwards yeah and
then after Disney went to like CW
maybe it was because where were the
Degrassi years I would say degrassiers
were like right before Disney Channel
because like right when hen Montana came
on like you couldn't catch us watching
anything else no we were so so loyal but
we also would watch the OC during that
time yeah we were busy kids yeah we were
busy we loved television we did like we
watched a lot of TV and I think that's
why we do what we do for a living
because like we had TVs in our bedrooms
growing up and like nobody else did but
I feel like I had the TV in my room but
I never watched that TV like I only
recall as a kid watching with you guys
no but like when you were in high school
you had a TV in your room yeah in high
school but I think a lot of people in
high school have I don't think so TV's
in their room like no when I was like a
kid kid I had a TV in my room and I
never turned it on now kids have like a
laptop so they don't really or like an
iPad they don't need a television yeah
no but I do I do feel like and I was
thinking about it when I was reading
Gary jannetti's book because he talks so
much about how he literally the basement
television changed his own school just
to watch CD like yeah one like 364 days
for one when they would like play The
Wizard of Oz on Christmas yeah and I
wonder like I feel like some kids who
watch so much TV like it turns into
being this like whole new world for them
and we do what we do he does what he
does probably because yeah but other
kids who watch so much TV it's not so
much what do you mean they're just like
TV
addicts well no they like go to
Comic-Con no they just like
like it's they are not social yeah what
are you trying to say they're just like
couch potatoes couch potatoes there I
said it yeah I guess maybe that'll be
USO in 10 years like who knows I think
we're a little young to be couch
potatoes currently yeah and I always
like now
as a mom I'm like okay I don't want my
kids to watch a lot of TV but that'll
fade we watched a lot of TV and I think
it only added to yeah where I mean I
wonder what we could have done if we
weren't watching all that TV uh right
like I could we probably could have been
like the next Mia ham yeah we kind of
would have been like Ilona Musk
literally I do
um
I do find cells and the fact knowing
like I'll never become a couch potato
because I hate sitting on my couch
you're a bad potato I'm a bad potato
yeah yeah I'm showing early stages of
bed potato I love that for you me too
um
and so check out People magazine for
Matthew Perry's full interview
yeah I feel like it needs to be a book I
agree
speaking of interviews Meghan markle's
on the cover a variety magazine do you
see no and she is sharing some
Revelations including Prince Harry's in
and out Obsession though that is not the
major headline here first she's done
with acting she says she was asked if
she'd consider acting again to which she
was oh I never thought of that too but
she responded quote no I'm done I guess
never say never but my intention is
absolutely not
I don't see why she would need to
oh
I feel like
I would have thought that she would be
open to it well I just would have
thought she's the type of gal who like
would train at like a talent or a skill
for many years and not give it up and
like that's her passion is acting and
now I don't think it is oh I well I just
would have assumed since that's what she
was doing and people who act like loved
loved like the Art Theater yeah she's
podcasting and doing a reality show so
right why not and I'm sure now like she
could have any part any job she wants
that's a good point no I don't I never
thought about it to me like I just
assumed the chapter was closed yeah yeah
I did too until she became a podcasting
reality star right right yeah
um but she said she's not done with
Hollywood because they signed the
multi-year deal with Netflix and The
Duchess discussed the docuseries helmed
by director Liz Garbus that will Center
on the couple she said this which was
interesting quote it's nice to be able
to trust someone with our story a
seasoned director whose work I've long
admired even if it means it may not be
the way we would have told it but that's
not why we're telling it we're trusting
our story to someone else and that means
we'll go through their lens it's
interesting my husband has never worked
in this industry before for me having
worked on suits it's so amazing to be
around so much Creative Energy and to
see how people work together and share
their own points of view I feel like
she's already trying to like put out the
narrative like get ahead of this stocky
series being like that's not
our version of events by saying that oh
that's interesting
um to be completely honest I have
literally no idea what she just said the
second okay this is the oh this is the
most what I mean
it's nice to be able to trust someone
with our story even if it means it may
not be the way we would have told it but
like it's your right she's like she's
like preemptively saying like she
doesn't like it no she's preemptively
saying like if you don't like it I
didn't do it
yeah like distance if there's a problem
with it it's Liz's lens
yeah blameless that's how this season
not her throwing Liz under the bus
before the show him in premieres yeah
yeah
um
for me I'm so looking forward to this TV
show like you have no idea
um
I am like constantly feeling like Megan
is saying sentences full of nothing like
she never does the word salad with word
salad what was that first sentence that
you just like when you were reading it I
was like what
um no I thought that the first half was
more meaty than the second half the
first half she said it's nice to be able
to trust someone with our story a
seasoned director whose work I've long
admired even if it means that it may not
be told the way we would have told it
um this next part I think that's more
three sentences that could have been one
but that's not why we're telling it
we're trusting our story to someone else
and that means it will go through their
lens
yeah
um
I
I just need to see the show like for
real like I need to see the show there's
been like lots of reports that it's like
they're having you know creative
differences I need to see the show yeah
they're literally like I'll be page six
and like the stories are next to each
other and one it's like
yeah it was Megan Harry Slam in the
royal family and new docu series like
one they want to push it back and then
the next one is like docu series is
coming out on time like Megan and Harry
love it and it's like
which is it you guys talk like which is
it I I don't think anything that I'm
reading about the stocky series
I agree the work I completely agree I I
am still like living in the space like
Prince Harry is a reality star like for
me it's so low brow I I'm shocked like
honestly if somebody offered me a
reality show like even I I probably
wouldn't do it like it's so even even at
Netflix like it's so tacky no I know and
up until now like the beauty of their
show is like it's they get to share
their story their truth and like their
side of things and we get to see them in
a way that they want us to see them and
now they're saying like they don't even
have that editorial control it's Liz's
right like so why so you're just like a
a real housewife no you're like
literally Alexis Snyder like you're just
a person on a reality show yeah no and
so for for Prince Harry to be that like
I just I didn't see that
yeah
I mean I don't I think that they do have
a lot of creative control but I do think
that this is like a good way of sewing
the seeds of being like
Liz did that right
there's a fall woman there's a fault
excuse me oh my goodness I think I'm
getting bored by Megan and Harry like
I'm I've reached my limit almost I know
but like she
is everywhere she's everywhere and she's
like on the cover of variety like
talking about all of these things she
said that she'd be fine if her kids got
into the entertainment industry she said
that her and Harry share our home office
so you know they're fighting a lot oh my
God why
um by the way though I don't like what
no never mind I was gonna say something
mean okay uh she said that Harry loves
in and out burger and
um she shared remember she did an
interview with the cut and people found
it to be snarky I forget what she had
said specifically but she addressed it
and said the New York Magazine story was
intended to support archetypes and focus
on our projects I've had some time to
reflect on it part of me is just really
trusting really open that's how I move
in the world I have to remember that I
don't ever want to become so jaded that
that piece of me goes away so despite
any of those things onward I can survive
it
again there's no end to the sentence
came off snarky in the interview it's
because like she was too trusting with
the magazine that they would and like to
open
okay
um
cool I'm wishing them the best cannot
wait for the TV show to come out
agreed
are you ready for our next story yes
ma'am ready worthy Royal news because
Daniel Craig has received his Royal
honor from Princess Anne saying we've
been expecting you it's beautiful Daniel
Craig now has another thing in common
with James Bond with a thoughtful and
poignant nod to his screen character the
late Queen Elizabeth made Daniel Craig a
companion of the Order of Saint Michael
and Saint George in January just like
the fictional spy on Tuesday the British
star received his honor from the Queen's
daughter Princess Anne at an investiture
ceremony held at Windsor Castle the
Royal Family's official social media
Pages used a famous phrase from the Bond
movies as they shared a photo of Craig's
appearance at the castle they wrote in
the caption we've been expecting you
it's beautiful it's absolutely beautiful
absolutely beautiful only would have
been more perfect if Queenie it's the
queen but
honestly I would have assumed he already
had one of these you know yeah but it's
cool it's really life imitating art you
know yeah but when I when I think about
like the celebrities who like have been
knighted or just like recognized I would
throw him in there you know Elton John
the beckhams Dame Judy Dench and Daniel
Craig like I would have already assumed
yeah
people making the UK proud yeah I need
to in the work and I think also you need
to be like a queen of file
you have to prove your loyalty you have
to have respect like we know now David
Beckham has the utmost respect for the
queen obsessed I wonder if James Corden
has respect for the queen
that's a really really good point I mean
I'm seeing so many more things of people
being like no there's been Rumors in the
UK that he's yeah a menace for years
like this is not the first we're hearing
of it but and then that clip was going
viral of him truth truth or spill like
where that show yeah
uh but he was the one doing it and
Stephen Colbert was interviewing him it
was like either drink this sperm or name
at least two of your cameramen
and he didn't know their names
that's disgusting
you've been on the show what for five
years already like
yeah wow
so I think I think we might be on to
something here I think we have the the
new Ellen yeah
crazy anyways yes happy for Daniel Craig
happy for the royal family like staying
on top of yeah stay winning stay winning
are you ready for a fifth and final
story yes Ramona's singer yes crashes
the Roney spin-off calls it quote The
Loser Show sorry it was so funny so
funny Roni Alum Ramona Singer shared her
unfiltered thoughts on Bravo's plan for
a legacy spin-off that features OG stars
of the Bravo reality show she said quote
I've been there for a long time I mean
never say no never say never but I also
feel like the Legacy show how could it
really be good the people they are going
to bring back are the people they didn't
want to renew anyways so now what are
you going to call it the loser show the
loser Legacy
she's not wrong well first of all the
vibe that I got is at Ramona officially
knows that she is not being asked to
return because now she's you know doing
press and making it seem like you know
she in this interview was filled with
really juicy she's like honestly I I
don't know if I would return for the OG
show I in the in the year that we've
been off I've really enjoyed not being
on TV I've I know this sounds crazy but
I don't really like attention like I
can't go to dinner I can't go on dates
like
it it sounded a little delusional like
and not believable but some of the
quotes like from her
presence on this podcast like sound
really grounded and not very ramona-like
you know no it like if they're genuine
it sounds like she's completely changed
right she said I don't know if I want to
do it again for a lot of reasons I'm
much calmer now that I haven't done the
show I know this is an oxymoron but I
really don't like being recognized she
said now that the show's been off all of
a sudden people aren't bugging me are
you Ramona I know you're on a date but
can I have a photo I don't like all the
attention and guess what the men I date
don't like all the attention even my
girlfriends don't
she said she used to go out in like 20
her friends would be like 20 people came
up to her and now it's like one person
comes up to her she also said that she
didn't enjoy interacting with the media
during her tenure as a housewife she
said quote I really don't like the press
the Press stressed me out with all of
that stuff that was really really
hurtful and made me really unhinged I
mean unhinged and I realize now I'm so
much more relaxed all my friends say I'm
50 more calmer I still have high energy
but I'm not as hard as there's something
more gentle and I'm actually able to
date now in a better way I also feel
like this jibes with what we were saying
about her Presence at bravocon where
it's like she didn't suck all the air
out of the room we barely knew that she
was there because she's just like this
calm that's actually true
that's actually a very good point and I
think her point that she originally made
about the loser show is an excellent
point like so yeah it's sad because all
these OG women are like iconic but Andy
himself said this is the lowest rated
season in Housewives history so people
actually don't care so you're gonna make
a whole separate show that nobody cares
about and
Ramona I don't believe is returning
Sonia and Luanne have their own show so
it's like you don't really need this
who else is there I think they're going
to bring Dorinda I know
I don't know but and honestly Leah now
that I think about it really is better
suited with this new crew yes for sure I
don't think she wants me on and I think
she will be on Legacy but maybe like
since Legacy would be on peacock they
have a lower threshold for viewing
requirements and the Roney Legacy crew
like does have an established audience
though dwindling like there is an
audience as opposed to coming up with a
whole new concept for a show yeah that's
true
I forgot that it was going to be on
peacock that's a good point and I think
that eventually Roni started to go
downhill because they had these like
women who are friends for 20 30 years
who have these erratic sort of fights
and then they also have like two or
three new people who are expected to
just jump right in and yeah they have to
keep evolving and bringing on new people
but you can't blend make both work yes
it's erratic so they had to make a
choice and they chose both but just to
split it up yeah no that's a good point
that maybe if they adjust if they had
even chose the ogs and move forward with
just being like you know what we're
gonna have these women who you guys know
for however many years and we're not
going to keep trying to bring in fresh
blood just like we'll let them do their
thing maybe that would have been better
than what we saw in season 13 which was
like trying to make something happen
trying to make fetch happen yeah I'm
just curious who the Legacy people are
gonna be because I don't think it's
going to be Ramona and like is it going
to be Jill maybe I think it will be
Luanne and Sonia they need to promote
their other show their others yeah Lou
Ansonia Dorinda Luanne Sonia Dorinda
Maybe chill like maybe Kelly
I don't think Kelly would ever return
maybe Cindy bar shop I know you would
like I wish
it's interesting
um so yes I I appreciated Ramona's
renewed POV if it was genuine it
definitely sounded like she's changed
quite a bit in the last year
yeah I don't think so and your point
about Bravo Khan is great I don't think
she'll be on the show because then she
will have just called herself a loser
yeah uh
and that actually makes me even less
excited than I was me too because she's
the only New York housewife who has been
a main cast mate since season one
okay like I agree people say that
because one season where Luanne got
demoted to Friend of but she still
brought it I consider Luanne to be
like that's semantics
he was still on that season and she was
at the reunion
just saying
it's semantics sure but it's also fact
s
um well those are the past five stories
you definitely needed to know them and
we still don't go anywhere have deer
toasters which is Our advice segment
that you can write into deertoesters
gmail.com and we'll do our best to help
you out for whatever it is that you're
going through deer toasters is brought
to you by Noom people will try almost
anything to lose weight insane workouts
eating nothing but grapefruit
questionable teas but if you're looking
for a more sustainable approach NuMe
weight is ready to help their
psychology-based approach empowers you
with knowledge and support to build
lasting results you can't erase the past
or change who you are and NuMe weight
gets that so every journey is different
and each person has a different goals I
know a lot of people want to get healthy
to fit into their clothes better to be
more active to keep up with their kids
whatever the reason is it's not always
the number on the scale and instead of
demanding the same strict regimen or
drastic changes from everyone with Noom
you'll get a personalized program that
empowers you to build more sustainable
habits that's how they've helped more
than 3.6 million people and Counting
lose the weight you'll get long-term
results and they come for more Flex
taxable Solutions so NuMe weight focuses
on progress instead of perfection
progress isn't a straight line off days
are totally normal and they are part of
the process new weight is just going to
help you get back on track so you don't
have to spiral feeling bad and then undo
everything that you've done because you
had one bad day it's not a big deal you
could choose the level of support that
you get from Noom from five minute daily
check-ins to even personal coaching and
the science says it all noom's weight
approach is based on scientific
principles like cognitive behavioral
therapy to help you better understand
your relationship with food they've
published more than 30 peer-reviewed
scientific articles about their methods
and the effectiveness 95 of customers
say new weight is along a good long-term
solution and active numerous lose an
average of 15 pounds in 16 weeks Jackie
I know that you have gotten really into
your new postpartum in like the last
month yeah thank you for noticing
looking stunning always always uh yes I
love Noom I personally love to use it
when I'm trying to hold myself
accountable and also keep track of what
I'm doing so I can look at it at a
glance and see you know if I'm not
getting the results that I want where I
could make changes where uh working out
versus how much I'm eating and what I'm
eating you know what the calories
consist of and Noom is the best app for
that to keep everything on track I'm
just like I feel like mentally like Noom
is like my internal planner you know
like I have my planner for my external
activities my noon for my internal
activities and currently I'm in the
season of rising and grinding and Noom
is the perfect pal to help keep you
accountable but also like is a good
friend to know that nobody's perfect and
they don't expect Perfection if you're
done trying everything to lose weight
then try new weight sign up for your
trial at noom.com toast that's n o o
m.com slash toast to sign up for your
trial today no what have you got to lose
what have you got to lose I've also
recommended Noom to so many friends who
um might be like for the first time
trying to lose weight and don't know
where to start I'm like start with new
with new because there's so much
information out there and also in order
to like
go on a you know to lose weight or go on
a diet like you need some of this
educational material which Noom has it's
hard to you don't know where to start
when you've never done it before
um are you ready we're going to change
some lives and this one I think is uh
something a lot of people relate to a
lot of engaged girlies hello Jackson
clerd I'm engaged in getting married in
New York City next summer the situation
is that I absolutely hate my fiance's
last name so much that I can't even say
my new my new name out loud I like
literally combust when I put first put
my first and new last name together I
feel terrible because my fiance knows
that I hate it but it's important to him
that I change it I'm traditional in the
sense that I want to change it too I'm
looking for advice on how to make my new
name roll off the tongue and be proud of
it even if it even if I cannot
physically say it out loud love you
girls this would be easier if we had
your name but of course we protect the
privacy of all of our submissions they
need to know the name I do have a friend
who was in this exact situation she goes
by her maiden name I literally had to
pull out of her to ask what her
husband's name was and she eventually
told me but I would never know wait who
are you talking about um one of my
friends down here
got it got it got it okay yeah
um
so yeah yeah yeah stick with your maiden
name if it really really bothers you but
also like I need to know no but also
like married names don't just like sound
right off the bat like I feel like I'm
still getting used to Claudia sopher
like it takes time and then by the time
you get married and then eventually have
kids then you'll really feel like a
family and it will feel so weird but of
course like I think the people who
change their Instagram name like the
night of their wedding it's like
psychotic like relax it takes time I
have mad respect for it I think if
you're gonna change your name
rip off the Band-Aid all like just go
all the way in and start like change
everything and people will start to
associate it like even like Dana who is
my best she made a new Gmail
like she changed everything you don't
have to do that but like I actually
really start to associate people with
their new name like when they just rip
off the Bandit and they're like call me
that takes a while but I get really used
to it and then I'm like oh my God I
can't believe they used to be blah blah
blah no and we love a Rebrand if the
name is even better it makes it so much
easier Lauren Lane yeah but that's not
her this girl's problem this girl's
problem she doesn't like how it is
period right and I need to know what the
last name is I know
um and if it's you're just gonna have to
do it it's really that bad then stick
with your maiden name like
no but she's traditional like this is
something that's important to her and
her fiance so there's nothing you can do
about it suck it up just make a choice
and then whatever choice you make like
act like it's a stick with it in the
world like if that is to your new name
whatever it is even if it's Duty balls
like right yeah
Judy balls party five and also at the
end of the day like you have a great
man's and you're proud to be like I am
Mrs Mrs Judy ball and you wish you were
so true stunt on the mother Duty balls
okay
just be that's true like how you embrace
it is is how people perceive it like if
you're being like Oh I know it's weird
like everyone's gonna be like yeah it's
weird but no if you're like proud and
you just own that [ __ ] like people
respect that confidence yeah
so that's my advice
hello is your queen McLarty and the
stress Bros the strikes Brothers they
don't ever get their [ __ ] ass up in
work anymore it's so hurtful they know
that these new chairs have no space for
them that's why I love listening to you
both every day and here's my dilemma
after two years of dating my boyfriend
I've moved him to his place and on the
day of the move he left to run some
errands I was unpacking and organizing
my things in his home and in one of the
bedrooms there was this old open
backpack that had a bunch of random crap
in it papers a water bottle an envelope
Etc now that I was moving in my motive
was to get rid of things that were
unnecessary and this backpack was at the
top of my list me not being a snoop but
just wanting to make sure I didn't throw
away anything of importance I looked at
what was in the envelope and it was a
prescription for Viagra I was shook when
was this prescribed was it for my
boyfriend lo and behold it was under his
name and the data prescription was
August 2022. not that having directile
dysfunction is anything that bothers me
we're both in our early 30s but I have
never ever suspected him to have one and
me being a freak such a normal girl in
my mind ran laps does he have a secret
life I don't know about why does he need
this whenever I suspected he needed some
assistance when we were together do I
bring it up to him I'm not really one to
dust things under the rug so I'm
basically just asking how to bring it up
sincerely a kerfuffled toaster I just
want to say I do think like if you're in
a serious relationship and
your man is on Viagra like that's
something that you should know of course
are you pretending like you're
decluttering by going through his
backpack is a joke no I don't agree with
that at all like I
Ben's I go through Ben's backpack
because literally it turns into a
pharmacy has like 45 bottles of zinc
like I think that there's totally life
like they're moving in together
up his space no it wasn't his current
backpack also it was an older back okay
but Zach started cleaning up the my the
bedroom and included going through my
purse different different okay so
different I'm I stand with this girl I
don't think she was being Snoopy at all
well regardless it doesn't matter how
you got the information even if it was
illegally obtained I don't think so you
have to deal with the information at
hand
and I do think you should bring it up
just something that came to mind at one
point in the last few years people were
saying that Viagra was actually
um perhaps a I don't I'm not a doctor
but they were looking into it as a
treatment for coven oh yeah maybe he had
a bad bout of covet and was trying you
know some alternative remedies no but if
that were the case like he would have
told you that but the fact that he
didn't makes me think it's for the
reason that Viagra is intended Ed but
also sometimes people they might not
have Ed but they pop a Viagra just see
because they want to [ __ ] all night long
yeah very Samantha Jones I would have if
this is a person that you're going to be
very serious with I would find a way to
bring it up in a yeah non-threatening
way no but also like it would bother me
that something like kind of serious
would be kept for me
um and I would feel as though the person
needed to be reprimanded for that
you know I think you need you would need
to set aside your anger
until you hear his reaction you know if
he like starts like gaslighting you
being like well why like you should know
what health things are going on with
your partner and I just think you should
just broach the subject yeah I guess
health is like confidential yeah it's
like nobody has to tell you but like
if Ben was taking like you know
cholesterol pills and didn't tell me
like I'd be like what the [ __ ] but
there's also a difference between a
husband and a boyfriend that's true but
moving in together is definitely you're
on that you're getting it makes it
serious so now things are turning
serious this is a time for maybe a
serious conversation and you did find
this information I I think you should
not hold on to it
no approach it in like a very
rationality open with him so yeah and
vice versa but vice versa Viagra versa
like you you just reproach it in like a
calm very rational very
tempered way and I don't think it'll be
like crazy yeah
all right third and final deer toasters
Jackson Claude my husband likes to post
unattractive photos of me on social
media the pictures are usually of me
asleep on the couch with my dog I've
told him it is embarrassing and I wish
he would at least check with me before
posting he doesn't understand why I get
pissed about it he says it is endearing
and it warms his heart I appreciate that
he wants to share his feelings about how
much he loves me on social media but why
can't he post a good [ __ ] picture am
I overreacting
honestly no first of all especially if
like he exclusively posts ugly photos of
you like one every now and then is like
funny a pattern is like kind of
diabolical yeah this would not fly
no and like maybe this is me looking
into it so much but it kind of makes me
feel like he's
like trying to make you
feel ugly like I know that sounds crazy
but like you've told him that it bothers
you he won't stop and he exclusively
posts photos of you sleeping on the
couch with the dog like
it it feels like kind of like crazy ass
manipulative it could be totally
innocuous but it also could be like a
really [ __ ] psychotic manipulative
thing to do it could be but it also
could be like really sweet like he
doesn't even notice that you don't look
how you think is beautiful like he's
yeah but if she says this is bothering
me and he doesn't stop like that's rude
yeah but he just like sees you as
beautiful no matter what you're doing
and like he just thinks that these
pictures used to be on the couch with
your dog is sweet and he's just like
trying to share it I don't know if he's
intentionally posting
ugly pictures or the pictures he's
taking
happen to be ugly well who looks
beautiful while so like who posts who
takes a picture of someone while they're
sleeping and posts it like
no it's diabolical until I wake up you
get the approval you just need to be
like I mean I think Zach like Zach would
never post a picture oh my God his
personality but like I he knows like you
can never be I've instilled the fear of
God and Ben that anything he posts
requires not one but two approvals yeah
like you cannot post an unauthorized
photo of course that are you crazy right
he's just trying to ruined my reputation
yeah no he just needs to know what
you're about and like you're not about
you have to lay down the law you're not
about that unauthorized life
yeah it's just like I I feel like when
it comes to men and social media like it
can never be normal like either they're
taking ugly pictures of you either they
won't post you like why can't you just
be normal yeah what's normal
taking pictures we both look at the
photo decide if we like it and then we
come up with a caption together yeah and
it's like always like a nice picture
maybe a wedding we were at a dinner
something where we're all dressed up or
we just moved into our house or we got a
dog we took a cute picture on self-timer
that we all like moments right like why
can't they just be [ __ ] normal
yeah but not like we're not posting
every day
no or not at all some of them like won't
even acknowledge their wives on social
media right but I feel like he's posting
these pictures to maybe stories so
what's the protocol for stories of your
partner
stories require a different set of roles
I agree yeah because they're more casual
so he's 100 pictures of her sleeping
he's a little too casual he's a little
too comfortable sir
and you have to lay down the law ASAP
you obviously just can't sleep in front
of him
right no now it's separate bedrooms
foreign
those were the deer toasters thinking to
everyone who wrote In And if you would
like to write in it's deertoesters
gmail.com if you have written in and we
have not gotten to you it might be
because a you're uninteresting
or no I'm getting B it's mostly because
your submission is too long like I don't
know if you guys saw this curd like it's
not that long it's like a paragraph at
most so try and keep it tight just the
need to know information and resubmit
and we'll do our best to get to you
thank you to everyone have a great hump
day Jax I'll see you tomorrow tomorrow's
episode will still be normal in studio
because my flight is right after the
episode so we'll do regular episodes I
was about to ask you and then we'll be
together for Friday and then all of next
week and then Halloween it's a Jackson
clerred special don't miss it thank you
so much for listening to the toast the
Millennia Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please remember to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's Spotify iTunes
digital public radio I Heart Radio cast
box all the places Webby listen podcast
find us some Morning Show sleeping
podcast beautiful standing and smart we
are hope you guys have an amazing hump
day don't forget to have someone you
love and we'll see you tomorrow bye